back in the gym actually and I'm eating
I found a way to eat how Through Your
Eyes doing it yeah it's through my ass
like the South Park episode I just sit
on a turkey I put Foods in a condom and
a little bit up and jam it on my ass
yeah I tell my stomach how's that yeah
yeah
eat that reverse eating yeah
so
my arms have gained like three inches
each really come on I don't know maybe
you went on teeth
that'd be insane growth I don't know
dude I've gained that in fat but more
three inches yeah that's easier though
I'm still trying to I I think I gained
six pounds when I like stopped training
with the no not over the break just over
the break I trained like so much good
but stayed the exact same way because I
was just eating and drinking yeah all
day long cookies oh I made croissants
yeah I made homemade croissants I saw
two batches
that [__] is so hard have you ever done
it dude it's a ridiculous processor I
never made a croissant
never taking time out of your busy day
to make a croissant
all the time but I mean how long does it
take it's a long time right time you
don't have yeah we need you here
yeah
by the way you may ever make croissants
Ryan yes I have you're fired yeah too
much free time yeah yeah
[Laughter]
okay so you make the dough how do you
make the dough
uh it's just like you you activate yeast
what is that what what was that what
were you just doing I don't know we were
on the close-up on you foreign
[Laughter]
what
I can't focus when you're doing that
doing what we're on the close-up on you
you keep like air jacking off no I'm not
you're airjacked dude you're making
you're making [__] up go ahead all right
so you lay the dough
he's playing the [__] air flute over
here
no okay you make the dough okay so you
activate the yeast and stop
you activate the yeast you mix it how do
you activate yeast you like put it in
hot water oh with like a little sugar
and then it like blooms and it like
breathes and then you mix it with some
flour some sugar as a Meg I thought you
activated yeast by just having her wear
dirty underwear for a couple days
foreign
gross I'm never gonna make croissants
ever again that's gonna gross me out
and so you activate the yeast infection
[Laughter]
hey I want to make croissants on Friday
oh
[Laughter]
so don't change your underwear
sorry sorry you activate the yeast
then you make the dough okay then you
proof it a couple times and then you
leave it overnight the next day you like
put Square uh you put like wax paper in
the shape of a square put the dough
inside you flip it over you like beat
the dough so that it goes to a square
and then you also have to do the same
thing with butter but a smaller square
and then you take the butter you put it
in the dough you fold it over top and
then it's like hours and hours of
folding and then waiting folding and
then waiting folding the dough over
itself like you know uh rolling it out a
little bit and then waiting some more
and then you do that again the next day
and then you cut it up into croissants
and you bake it
and then you have to let the croissants
prove before you bake it and then you
bake them so it's like overall it's like
two to three day process
so but they were so worth it oh my God
nice incredible you a pastry fan
you like to no yeah I've seen you eat a
couple pastries before last song yeah
I'll eat one yeah
yeah I'm not
I'm not I don't eat one and go
oh
laughs
that's what I was doing yeah yeah
oh wait there's so many things oh yeah
oh yeah yeah come here you're my little
fly out I waited three days for you
come here mwah no I yeah you know yeah I
don't get geeked over them
but you know I don't I don't love food
this is rewarding you know yeah I've got
three days doing something to that point
for New Year's Eve I I whipped up some
chicken cutlets oh for the gang breaded
nice in and out the hot oil nice they
were golden yeah that shit's good too
yeah I made chicken parm one time
chicken parm sandwich did that [__]
so good I nailed it they genuinely
nailed it let's go yeah were they good
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not even phased
by Cash's reaction there because you
don't even have to lie you can't even
try to lie
also he has the black dude about the
Fried Chicken
what okay
okay that's a reach that is a reach
I'm kidding I'm kidding okay did you
like the fried chicken I did do you like
our tiramisu
oh
I mean I didn't eat any dessert oh you
[__] I literally had a bite of the
ricotta cake
yeah
but yeah no no I I feel you on when you
cook something well yeah it is rewarding
oh Luke I'ma come back there and whoop
your ass that looks good
that looks [__] good you're this
isn't a reference to what Hunter showed
us I don't know what you're talking
about you [__] dude wait what
it's for the
um what we'll have to wait for the
episode to drop okay what is it it's the
literally the most disgusting [__] ever
what I will start puking it like okay
bleep this out it's like the fourth
stretch and fade episode
Hunter dude
oh
you dude
yeah that's fine
man yeah all right so yeah that's what
you can expect with stretch and fade
no um yeah we got something on the way
uh it's gonna be great other than that
it's great but that I
but I think
after Hunter did that we embarrassed the
[__] out of him in a way that I've never
seen why what let's just say we revealed
his family
okay
and uh
it was hysterical okay I've never seen
Hunter like that in my entire life he is
an embarrassing family no no no no no no
careful
[Laughter]
he was just very bashful about
discussing his family okay and I've
never seen him react that way it's just
it's yeah yeah you'll have to tune in
okay when's it coming out
February
okay something like that
uh so in episode four will be in March
okay so yeah like two months hey happy
New Year
dude also sorry we should start doing
that like promoting like big movies do
like a year like Barbie is right now
yeah Barbie's like summer 2025
we should start doing that with the
podcast just make up podcasts not even
make them just promote them oh that one
we got coming out with uh Dax in six
years yeah
Dax Shepard yeah it's gonna be amazing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's called
armchair dumbass yeah yeah
yeah how's that for a joke
yeah
yeah he's not hosting it no it's he's
not hosting it now we actually have an
AI version of him yeah yeah it's not as
good as him that's why it's armchair
dumbass yeah
oh dude I had a
stroke
you good